should i look into the lens uh i don't
think so
we get it yep
why was the movie never completed
let's start at the beginning
it was supposed to be a music
documentary
concert footage interviews you know
i wanted people to know who i really am
so i asked my best friend to direct it
we're gonna film everything just be
i love yourself
i was hoping to get a little uh after
show footage y'all just did
double double word score damn it read
them and weep
[Music]
you're nerdy and normal in real life but
the disparity between that and who are
on stage is jarring
i can be st vincent all the time so that
i can be a little bit more interesting
[Applause]
this is how actors play rock stars in
movies
yeah but you you are a rock star i mean
i know rock stars like
i love you but i'm married to the road
have a good show
[Music]
[Music]
she's weird you don't see that don't
really see it at all
[Music]
hi carrie we want you to film us
i need more say in how other people are
going to act it's a documentary then
let's only document things i can control
we're in this together me and me
i don't think i know what we're doing
i can't elicit anything authentic from
you anymore
what story did you think we were trying
to tell
your story
of course
[Music]
[Applause]
also
this is the only item i'll be selling at
my shows
[Music]
you